hello from Westminster on the agenda
today we've got Prime Minister's
Questions coming up it's hard to predict
what the questions will be but no doubt
there'll be some mention of the Ofsted
report that's out today that looks into
how councils are coping with mechanisms
for dealing with child abuse and the
report finds that there's a lack of
leadership and poor planning despite the
fact that statutory guidance was
introduced five years ago many councils
have only just begun looking at this
problem and so the recommendations are
that they get their guidance in place
publish it and implement it also later
in the Commons today we're going to have
another debate on the European Arrest
Warrant but specific to the warrant
itself which has been called by Labour
because of what happened last week when
there was debate on the subject without
actually specifically mentioning the
warrant itself this is an effort to
embarrass the Conservatives and to
perhaps get some of those rebels from
the back benches out they are being
encouraged not to attend this debate so
we'll see what happens there but of
course the big political happening today
is the last day of electioneering and
campaigning in rochester and strood
before the big vote tomorrow